uh the next are striking movements
so the first five were all thrusting
movements
and uh they are in sections in blocks
and uh really the cannon joe should feel
the same
on these uh on these next two
the sixth and seventh the ken and joe
should feel the same
if your intent in my posture
it's like the second cancer burning
you come up don't have the elbows out
too much
look look
past this elbow look
past this elbow
don't have don't have a big hole here
your elbows are wider than
your shoulders they need to be
kept inside remember other films that
i've
said if you can walk through a door with
your shoulders
you should be able to with your elbows
if you can't with your elbows because
they're sticking
wider than your shoulders since they
used to say that is too wide
a lot of people have this fault because
they weren't taught by it
you can come forward if you wish
looking straight ahead don't
turn too much because now you'll notice
that my old
my arm is blocking my my arm is blocking
my
uh face my eyes i can't i can't see
so don't don't turn the body to an angle
where you can't see
if you want to step back
you can
drop it as low as you can don't have the
fingers
open both loosely
for the beginner you should tell them to
keep both hands closed
permanently as you advance once you get
the black belt and perhaps beyond
you can have one hand open and one hand
closed
the pros and cons
the gap should be one of your fists
apart
one of your fists apart not wider
or not closer
not closer or wider
same as the cat
watch the front foot it would turn when
when my hips come forward the same as
with the other skis
i'm using my hip power
my head
[Music]
so
another fault that you'll see people do
is they become the enemy rather than
just uh doing the x form
like this when when they
get to this position their upper body
goes forward like this
that means to me they're in an
attacker's mode
they're not in a i'm in a neutral mode
i'm waiting for you to attack
[Music]
good starts good posture
body over the hips
advance forward
not not this
because the torso then is going forward
not not this not leaning forward
pros and cons
okay so this is
the start of the next series
the v on the hand is the same
as earlier with the joe same as this
back one
the v and the v
don't have them don't have them turned
over like this
look it closes in my it closes my frame
my frame doesn't want to be open but it
doesn't want to be
tightly closed
extend it away from you
not too close not too far away as if
you're being pulled
comfortable comfortable your body's
over its own center
okay
this is the start of the uh striking
movements
don't we're gonna